en el centro histórico de roma la
capital italiana no es raro encontrar
uno de los productos guatemaltecos más
conocidos y apreciados por los italianos
el café
esteban importa cada año casi 20.000
kilos de café que llega directamente de
este país centroamericano nosotros
compramos mucho café de guatemala porque
es un café natural biológico con estos
métodos naturales logramos sacar los
verdaderos aromas del café aromas ple
visitados por los clientes de este lugar
es delicado pero al mismo tiempo se
siente el sabor toda mi familia lo
consume
como el café y otros productos
guatemaltecos tienen éxito en italia
prueba de ello es el aumento de las
exportaciones guatemaltecas a la
península italiana en los últimos dos
años las exportaciones guatemaltecas
italia cruzaron 12 por ciento en total y
esto creo que se debe también a la
preferencia del consumidor italiano a
sus productos con certificados de
sostenibilidad productos como el aceite
de palma el cacao el azúcar o las frutas
en este restaurante elche
apasionado de américa latina' combina
los platos típicos de la tradición
gastronómica italiana con los
ingredientes que recibe directamente del
guatemala me gusta este matrimonio entre
la cocina italiana y los ingredientes de
guatemala y entonces se me ocurrió una
preparación con burrata un queso
típicamente italiano con el aguacate
para hacer una lasaña blanca y verde en
el resultado se hace agua la boca
todas las años
para los clientes del lugar es un
descubrimiento verdaderamente inusual el
aguacate se amalgama súper bien con los
demás ingredientes nunca había probado
algo así está buenísimo las
exportaciones guatemaltecas a italia
representan unos 167 millones de euros
anuales y se espera que sigan aumentando
en los próximos años